Adrian Perez Salazar is a political
analyst and attorney he joins us live
now from guil Welcome to the program so
why have gang leaders and crime cartels
seemingly become so powerful in Ecuador
over a relatively short period of time
what has been the root cause of
this thank you very much for having me H
the causes are multiple but uh what is
particularly important to emphasize here
is we're dollarized economy so naturally
it's much more easier for uh
International crime to uh to launder
money in a place like Ecuador and uh
this is not something that uh has uh
started recently this is something that
has been building up for many many years
uh past policies were very LAX in terms
of uh immigration very LAX in terms of
uh allowing gang leaders to to establish
dominance in areas such as as the
prisons and it's only the last couple of
years that we are seeing all the results
of many many years of of of these
structural problems being uh exacerbated
right so can the president not only put
a lid on this but also reduce the levels
of crime that have so Afflicted the
nation
it is very very hard uh NOOA has just
issued a state of emergency and uh has
declared a internal uh an internal armed
conflict which is essentially a
declaration of war he has labeled these
criminal organizations as belligerent
groups and while it's not completely
clear right now what are all the legal
ramifications of his decision this is
something that's completely
unprecedented the state
uh the state purpose of this is that he
wants to allow uh the military to
intervene directly in the conflict and
not only the police and he wants to give
them a ample room to use lethal force
and this is something that is applauded
by most of the population it there's
this general feeling that uh we have
completely lost control of our country
and that if we don't do something very
drastic right now then we're is going to
become a failed State given what you say
I mean how worrying is this for the
wider region as well for example Peru on
on the southern
border it is very concerning this is not
something that has only happened in
Ecuador uh Ecuador is probably the the
one that has been more affected by this
by this increasing in Gang Related
violence but the whole of Latin America
has seen an upsurge in in violence in
recent uh recent months part of the
reason why it's becoming so H so serious
right now is is probably because of the
fentel crisis in the United States you
see H gangs here in Latin America
produce cocaine and that that's their M
their main export in into the American
Market but recently as it's very well
known the American market and now has a
preference for for fentanyl which is not
produced in in in Latin America and what
this causes is that all these criminal
organizations are all of the sudden
starved for money and this makes them
more violent more aggressive and more
willing to find other ways to um to
finance their operations such as
kidnapping or extortion and this is not
something that has only happened in
Ecuador this is Ecuador is probably the
the most affected of all countries but
this is this is something that you can
also see in Colombia Bolivia and other
Latin American countries